Oh
I am NOT a gay blogger I am a blogger
who talks about celebrities who happens
to be a gay man who also happens to be a
Latino so I never claimed to be a
spokesperson for any community I'm just
me but having said that I talk about gay
issues on my website a lot and it
wouldn't really make much sense to a
normal person to be doing that if I was
like a girl but I'm thankful that I'm
gay and that I have the opportunity to
reach over 10 million people a day and
share with them things that I think are
important
I think that being out has only helped
me the moment I started being out in my
life I was instantly happier because i
was able to live an authentic existence
i was able to truly be me
I don't think I know how to be discreet
I was born this way